fresh berries are delivered to the
wholesale market on the outskirts of
Warsaw it's 6am the night was bitter
cold pava sep koffsky had to spend the
night here the first customers start
arriving at 3am pava is a student and
runs his own small business right now
he's trying to sell two tons of beans
yes brother unfortunately the prices
have fallen yesterday's supply was much
bigger than demand lo de lisboa ah but
the beans have to go pavel and his
business partner end up selling them at
a loss
it's a hard lesson for pava most
delicious go we sold everything huh but
we lost a little money Otto not just a
little we lost a lot huh well the price
went down Papa hasn't slept in 30 hours
but he still has another appointment
ventana I'm really exhausted now I'm
ready to wash my face and brush my teeth
he's a good up son he's headed to the
University Pavel is graduating this
summer from the Warsaw School of
Economics one of poland's top business
schools but even a degree from here is
no guarantee of success on the job
market his English skills are less than
impressive and there are more graduates
than jobs there are now one and a half
million university students in Poland
and the number is growing rapidly along
with the competition for jobs Poland's
economy is booming but the number of
unemployed academics rose to 250,000
last year I don't think anyone will hire
me the kogi ship what's good son I'm not
even thinking about the future because
the prospects in my field is so abysmal
there's almost diversity it's hard
finding a job that fulfills your
expectations interested that's why so
many young people are leaving the
country they include some of paula's
fellow students doctoral candidates
Dorota soaps tell is looking to start
her career abroad she says there's no
other choice
but they don't need some problem is to
those the biggest problem is the lack of
jobs your first job pays next to nothing
but the expectations are enormous
graduates are supposed to have 10 years
of experience and work for nothing
that's just not possible origami I just
gonna do that they're just owes me
handsome morning one of these cars
up with the 10 per kilogram 11 okay
buying and selling four crates of
blueberries is hardly a challenge for
the trained economist but he's lucky to
turn a profit right now he's hoping to
win over Warsaw's famous blickling
confectionery as a customer that would
give him a much-needed financial boost
the delightfully fresh Pablo hopes to
expand his deliveries eventually
exporting polish produce to Germany the
gospel things my original career plans
were totally different going into this
business was a spontaneous decision and
there are some nice moments like getting
to supply the best confectionery in
Warsaw gabbatha out here Pavel studies
are the last thing on his mind it looks
like he'll spend another night at the
market